[Music]
all right welcome back
so we've been talking about complex
functions and specifically analytic
complex functions
where we essentially have uh enough of a
well-defined
you know notion of a derivative that we
can do calculus we have taylor series
now we're going to talk about kind of
what integrals look like in the complex
planes and you know we spent a lot of
time looking at derivatives we found
weird properties like the derivative of
a complex function sometimes depends on
the direction
uh you know of kind of how i approach
that point but for analytic functions
the derivative is independent
of the way that we approach that point
in the complex plane
today we're going to talk about complex
integrals
and specifically we're going to be
talking about
a function so given
a function
f of z
and we're going to break this up into
its real and its imaginary part so we're
going to say f of z has a real part u of
x comma y
plus i of v
sorry i v of x comma y
uh and of course you know
where
uh my function my variable z equals x
plus i y
x is the real part y is the imaginary
part of my complex variable z and my
function f has a real
part uh u which is a function and a an
imaginary part v which is a function
we're going to be talking about
computing the integral of this function
f over paths in the complex plane maybe
closed circles maybe you know a path
from point z naught to z one and we're
gonna see uh you know when does that
integral depend on the path i take when
are those integrals equal to zero things
like that
and you might ask yourself
why would i care about integrals in the
complex plane i live in the real world
i'm a real valued human
why do i care about things like uh
you know a
let's say that this is my real part and
this is my imaginary part and this is my
complex plane
why should i care
about uh you know the integral from
one point to another in the complex
plane
now one of the the reasons is of course
that you get to impress all of your
friends at your next party uh with how
complicated of an integral you can do uh
you know on the back of an envelope you
can really solve some pretty hairy
definite integrals using uh integrals in
the complex plane in fact kind of in the
olden days before you know mathematica
and wolf from alpha and numerical
computation
there were nasty real valued integrals
integrals that matter to real humans
like us
that you could kind of only solve by
extending that real valued integral into
the complex plane and using some of the
fancy complex integral tricks i'm going
to show you in this lecture and the next
couple of lectures that's one reason
that's kind of a superficial reason and
realistically nowadays
we have computers you probably don't
need
unless you're on a desert island you
don't need to you know often do these
integrals in the complex plane we have
computers for these now if you're on a
desert island and you want to design an
airfoil again you're going to be needing
to do integrals in the complex plane
when i compute the lift over an analytic
kind of an idealized air foil using
potential flow i'm definitely using
complex integrals
so it's really good for building
intuition for things like you know flow
over wings or electrostatic potentials
or steady state heat equations we might
need kind of the intuition of of the
complex plane that we can use when we
then
uh extend these into really
uh you know modern numerical
computations of these things
one of the areas that this is the most
important is when we do inverse laplace
transforms so the inverse laplace
transform is going to involve a complex
integral an integral
uh a closed loop integral in the complex
plane
and we are only going to be able to
solve that once i show you all of the
kind of tricks and theorems and facts
and properties and intuition of
integrals in the complex plane so if you
are serious about you know control
theory
partial differential equations
fluid dynamics physics
you might not use these for day-to-day
computations anymore but this is still
one of the underpinnings of how we
understand the computations that we do
outsource to our computers
okay
integrals in the complex plane so we're
talking about these functions of a
complex variable z that have a real and
imaginary part
uh
and i'm just going to write out a couple
of properties
of this really really quickly so that um
essentially so so that you can see how
this expands out
so if i have a function f of z
uh then
you can see i've been in the complex
plane a lot i just put down one blue pen
and picked up another blue pen uh then
the
contour integral some integral and i
actually don't have to say that it's a
closed contour or an open contour just
some
integral over some contour c from some
point to some other point it could come
back to itself that's fine
the integral of sum contour
c of my function f of z
with respect to the z variable
and i'm going to expand this
times dz
this is going to equal
u
plus iv
that's just f this is the integral of u
times dz which is just dx plus i d y
and this is actually super simple we're
just going to you know multiply all four
cross terms and collect the reals and
the imaginaries
and so that equals uh that equals
the integral over my contour of
all the real stuff is going to be
u dx
minus so i times i is minus
minus
v d y
that's all the real stuff plus i times
all the complex stuff which is u i d y
so u
d y
plus
v
d x
okay so this is just what happens when i
take a complex function times dz and i
expand it out and we're going to
integrate this over contour c from you
know maybe from some point uh
z naught to z one
maybe we will uh integrate from z naught
back to itself so a closed contour and
we're gonna see what happens when this
function is analytic and when this
function is not analytic very important
cases here okay
so that's where we're going with this
um
and anything i want to point out before
i get into kind of the theorem what you
should notice already is that this
expression here
looks a lot like something that we can
transform using green's theorem which is
kind of the 2d version of stokes's
theorem from vector calculus
and this also looks strikingly like the
form that we saw in the koshi riemann
conditions earlier
so you know kind of hint or or teaser if
my function f is analytic and it
satisfies the koshi riemann conditions i
might be able to simplify or even cancel
out some of these expressions so that's
that's what we're going to see
um
[Music]
good and i think what i'm going to do is
i'm actually going to
write down this koshi
gorsa theorem over here because this is
super duper important
so the koshi
not couchy koshi gorsa
theorem uh please someone in the
comments tell me if gorsa is on the
eiffel tower i can't remember
and this is an important one this is
important this is one of my favorite
ones it's kind of a cornerstone i'll be
honest with you i'm not going to tell
you any complex integral formulas or
theorems that i found boring i found you
know i took a 15-week complex analysis
class and i distilled it down to the two
weeks i think you need to know so yeah
i'm gonna put important near almost all
of the theorems because i only pick the
ones i think are important
okay
so um
[Music]
if
my function f is analytic
in a closed uh
in a domain so let me just think about
how to say this if
f of z
is analytic
is
analytic and i'm going to say this two
or three different ways using kind of
mathematical legalistic uh lawyer speak
and you're going to realize why i have
to be particular about how i say this
if f z is analytic
inside
and on
a closed
a simple i'll tell you what i mean by a
simple
closed curve
c
which is this which is inside the
complex plane if f is analytic
everywhere inside of a simple closed
curve c in the complex plane
then
the integral the the closed integral
over c of f of z
dz
equals zero
this is the koshi gorsa integral formula
theorem and it's very very important
so
maybe i'll draw one more
[Music]
curve in the complex plane to give you
an idea what i mean so real and
imaginary
here what we're talking about is this
closed curve c
that loops back on itself and the
convention and complex analysis is that
these curves are typically
uh counterclockwise so they go kind of
so i'm integrating in this direction
this is important later it's not
important for this because it doesn't
matter if i integrate clockwise or
counterclockwise it's still zero but
later when we integrate around
non-analytic points it will certainly
matter if it's clockwise or
counterclockwise remember going up that
logarithm infinite spiral staircase if
you go clockwise you counterclockwise
you go up if you go clockwise you go
down
maybe there's religious overtones i'm
not sure
so this is my contour c
which is closed and simple so it's a
closed contour it's just a loop
okay
and what we are assuming is that my
function f is analytic everywhere inside
and on this contour c meaning there's no
singularities there's no cusps there's
no cliffs
uh kind of like you know there's nothing
weird happening inside of here it's just
an analytic function like z squared or z
cubed or e to the z or cosine of z where
it's analytic inside of here
so what i'm actually going to do is i'm
going to basically draw some domain d
and i'm going to say that it's analytic
everywhere inside of this domain d so
it's analytic
inside
okay so as long as my closed contour c
is kind of inside of an analytic domain
and it's analytic everywhere inside of
there it's analytic and here as well
okay it's analytic all the way inside of
that closed curve then this integral
around this closed loop equals zero
now
intuitively
if you like physics or engineering like
i do
like engineering more than physics
sometimes
then this feels a lot like a
conservative vector field right so like
a potential
a potential function so if i look at my
gravitational potential and i hike up a
mountain and i hike down the mountain if
there's no friction or losses
then you know the total uh gain and
energy around that closed loop is zero
because it's a potential function it's
the
uh you know that vector field that i'm
fighting against is the gradient of a
potential function and so i have this
kind of conservative property that the
integral equals zero
this is the theorem i'm actually going
to prove
because it's
intuitive and it actually illustrates
something useful to prove it if i don't
prove something for you it's probably
because it's either too complicated or
it's not that enlightening this one it's
actually enlightening to prove so i'm
going to prove
proof
this one's not that bad okay so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
this integral of c and this is a closed
contour c
of f of z dz
and from over here what we're going to
do is break this up into
the real part and the imaginary part a
real valued integral and an imaginary
valued integral so this is
this integral over c of u dx
minus
v d y
plus the imaginary integral
of c of what is that v dx
plus u d y i hope that's right i think
that's right good
so these are two real valued integrals
that i've split this up into two real
valued integrals uh this one plus i
times this real valued integral and now
what we're going to do is we're going to
see how both of these real value
integrals equal zero as long as my
function is analytic everywhere on and
inside
that uh that contour c
and so this is actually pretty simple
we're going to use green's
green's theorem so kind of uh where do i
want to go like equals
so this is
by
green's
theorem
this thing equals
so green's theorem from vector calculus
and you can go to my vector calculus
videos if you like and basically look at
green's theorem or stokes's theorem
this integral of a closed contour of u d
x minus v d y can be written as a
surface integral or an area integral of
you know over all the points inside of c
this can be written as a double integral
inside of c
kind of inside this
this region
that i'm going to call s over this area
s
of and just go go remind yourself what
green's theorem is of minus partial
partial v dx
minus partial
udy
that's what you get when you apply
green's theorem to this so you basically
take the different like uh if it's u d x
then you get a partial u d
y a minus partial u d y
and if it's v d y you get a partial v dx
so that's what this is um
you know dxdy
this is the real valued integral
plus
this imaginary valued integral which we
can also apply uh green's theorem to so
my v dx now becomes partial v partial y
and my u d y becomes partial u partial x
so i get partial u partial
x
minus partial v
partial y again this is d x d y
but the really really neat thing is
remember our cauchy riemann conditions
for an analytic function
because this is analytic everywhere
inside of here
this exactly equals
zero and this exactly equals zero
because our cauchy riemann conditions
were that this term equals that term and
this term equals that term those were
you know basically uh
you know by koshi riemann by
koshi riemann so go back to the video on
koshi riemann pause it write down the
koshi riemann condition one koshy room
on condition two and you'll see clear as
day that this whole integrand has to
equal zero both of these integrands
equal zero everywhere that this function
is analytic and since we've specified
that this is analytic everywhere inside
of this closed contour c
these are both identically equal
to zero so that's kind of why i chose to
show you this proof because it's
actually very intuitive and clear
how if you actually write out this kind
of expanded
form in terms of these these
differential elements and you apply
green's green's theorem
you basically see that if the function
is analytic both the real and the
imaginary part of this integral are zero
everywhere because of koshi riemann
because f is analytic and so this closed
contour integral equals zero
and this is super super useful this
property that the integral
over any closed curve of an analytic
function that's analytic you know kind
of everywhere inside that closed curve
is equal to zero we're going to use that
to do some pretty interesting things in
the complex plane we're going to do
surgery to you know deform this thing we
can basically warp this integral and it
won't change we're going to show for
example
one major implication is that
if i integrate
over two different paths if i integrate
over c1
and i integrate over c2
as long
as my function is analytic you know kind
of uh everywhere between c1 and c2
the integral does not depend on the path
super super interesting okay so i get
this kind of path independence in the
complex plane as long as my function is
analytic
okay
now uh if there are singular points like
if there's a singular point in the
middle that's not going to be true
but but let's say you know if my
function is analytic everywhere or
inside of a large domain where i'm
considering my trajectories then that
certainly is true
okay
uh so what am i going to do what i'm
going to do next is i'm basically
going to show how
this koshi gorsa theorem implies that
the integral is independent of path
i'm going to also show how that's true a
different way
and then i'm going to show that you can
do weird things like deform your curves
you can do surgery
and kind of show that other curves are
equal to zero and things like that
cool okay
so given this theorem it's almost kind
of obvious that this
integral is independent of path now
because if i write down
that i have an integral
from you know over path c1 which goes
from z naught to z1
of you know f of z
dz
and i have i'm claiming that this equals
the integral of c2 another
curve
of that same f of z
dz
because this should be independent
of the path
and the reason is is because that this
curve i drew here i could equally well
write it i'm going to try to just be an
artist here for a minute
i could basically take
you know
and reverse the direction of c2 this is
kind of minus c2 the minus c2 direction
and now i have a closed loop and the
integral of that closed loop has to
equal 0.
so just using some kind of
math notation here i'm going to say that
this equals the integral of c1
uh you know f of z dz
minus the integral of c2
f of z dz
equals zero
minus the integral of c2 is the same as
the integral you know in the opposite
direction in the minus c2 direction
so this equals integral of c1
i'm going to say now f of z
dz
plus the integral in the minus c2
direction
of f of z dz
and uh if i take you know in the c1 a
path in the c1 direction and then in the
minus c2 direction that's a closed
contour i'm going to say that that's a
closed contour c
this whole thing here is c
of f of z d z and that of course equals
zero by the koshi gorsa theorem so by
the koshi gorsa theorem
i can kind of show that if i have you
know two points z naught and z one and i
have a pat two different paths between
them
inside of an analytic domain
that integral has to equal the same
thing if i take path one or path two
and these uh these integrals themselves
don't equal
sorry um
these integrals themselves do not equal
zero
this implies that when i subtract their
integrals they equal 0. these integrals
themselves do not have to equal 0. the
integral from 0 to z1 might be you know
pi or 3 or 10
and it doesn't depend on the path i take
whether it's c1 or c2 good
uh and this is essentially like the
fundamental theorem of complex complex
variables actually so i'm going to erase
this and i'm going to write down the the
fundamental theorem of complex variables
okay so the fundamental theorem of
complex variables
um
yeah fundamental remember the
fundamental theorems of calculus
fundamental theorem
of you know complex uh integral calculus
calculus the fundamental theorem of
complex integral calculus
is that if
f
is analytic
in some domain d
which is kind of encapsulating you know
these curves in some domain d
and
z naught and z one are in that domain
d
then the integral from z naught to z one
over any path i take that remains in
that domain d over c one or c two or c
three or whatever the integral from from
z naught to z one of f of z
dz
is equal to some function you know f
evaluated at z one minus some function f
evaluated
at z zero so there is a function which
is the integral of f of z remember just
like there's a function that's the
derivative if i have an analytic
function
there is a function which is the
integral of f and all i have to do is
evaluate that function at the end point
minus the initial point and it doesn't
depend on the path
so for example you know if little f of z
is equal to z squared then big f of z is
equal to z cubed over three right it's
exactly like what you intuit
uh for com for real valued functions um
in the in the complex plane
now um there's something that sometimes
i tell my students when i'm in an
hour-long class and it's a little
technical so i'm going to post a link to
the the pdf notes that i use kind of my
handwritten or or typed up notes
uh about this
but i do think this is kind of
interesting
which is um
this function f
uh is the integral of little f big f is
the integral of little f and this
essentially relies on what is known as
um
udx minus uh v d y
and v d x
plus u d y basically the internal parts
of the real and imaginary parts of this
integral
are what are called exact differentials
exact differentials
and exact differentials that that
phrasing basically means
um
that
uh you and v satisfy the koshi riemann
conditions you can kind of verify this
for yourself but what that means is that
u equals uh f sub x
and v equals minus f sub y the partial
derivative of f with respect to x the
partial derivative of f with respect to
y
we also have i think
u
equals
g sub x and v equals g sub y
where um
goodness gracious i should have called
this you know um
this is some some complex function f
where complex f
is f plus i g so this this uh
non-squiggle f is the real part
and this non-squiggly g is the the
imaginary part of this kind of master
integral formula uh integral
f tilde
sorry that's a little confusing i just
use f twice to mean the same thing when
i said that little
f integrates to big f this function has
a real and an imaginary part and i'm
calling that real part
you know capital f and i'm calling that
imaginary part capital g okay so i hope
that's not not confusing
um and essentially what it means for
these to be exact differentials is that
u is the you know partial of f with
respect to x and the partial of g with
respect to
x and v is minus partial f partial y and
v is partial g partial y and you can
kind of confirm for yourself just like
we did here
because these are exact differentials
you can write this expression
and uh the koshi riemann conditions
uh are are satisfied here okay so um
this is just a technical detail maybe um
you know if you want to think about this
more you can look at my notes i make a
connection that essentially um this
establishes a conservative vector field
in the sense of you know vector calculus
and partial differential equations uh
but that's really a detail
so what do we what are we finding here
if we have a function f that's analytic
inside some domain d where we have a
closed contour then the integral around
that closed contour is equal to zero
because of you know green's theorem and
then koshi riemann
and that has the implication that if i
have two points the integral between
those two points is independent of the
path again because if i take two paths i
can kind of you know flip one of them
get a closed contour that equals zero
and so the integral of c1 has to equal
minus the integral of minus c2 which
means the integral along path 1 has to
equal the interval along path 2. very
very cool property
okay i'm going to show you a couple more
things you can do just kind of what i
consider surgery in the complex plane or
you know deforming these complex curves
so again i'm going to erase this and
then
i'll show you what those what those look
like so just one second
okay we just erased the board and moved
some stuff over here
so now i'm going to show you how you can
continuously deform these contours and
not change the value of the integral
as long as you are continuously
deforming it inside of a analytic
region d okay
and this is super cool i think about
this is like um you know warping these
curves or doing some surgery
and this is this is one of my kind of
favorite pictures i like to
uh i like to draw in the complex plane
so uh just to restate koshi gortha
gorsa's integral
integral theorem this is an integral
theorem
uh if my function f of z is analytic
inside
my my contour c
then the integral
of f of z dz equals zero
and so here's where it gets really
really interesting um
let's see how i want to do this
so
there's actually two
important properties i want to show you
so inside
inside
an analytic
analytic
region or domain
d
we can we can deform
deform
contours continuously we can deform
contours c continuously
and not change the value of the integral
and
not
change
the value
of the integral
cool uh and so i'm going to draw two
pictures actually because this is super
interesting so so in the one picture
it's kind of the one i drew here where
we have the real
uh and the imaginary
and i have you know
let's say contour
one
and i have
contour two
as long as
this one's kind of obvious as long as
these are both inside of a domain d
that's you know everything inside of
here is analytic
then uh the integral of c1 equals the
integral of c2 i can kind of deform c1
into c2 and nothing changes
now this is obvious in a sense because
both the integral of c1 and the integral
of c2 are both equal to zero so it's
kind of obvious that yes like every
closed curve inside of here has an
integral zero so that's like
uh in some sense trivial
so i'm just going to write this down
that the um
the integral
of c1 of f of z dz
dz
equals the integral of c2 these are
closed contours of f of z
dz they both equal zero they're equal to
each other and they're equal to zero
but what's really cool is that this is
actually true i can also deform these
contours
even if my um my contour is surrounding
some singular points where the function
is not analytic and this is going to be
super super useful later
so the other case that's actually
interesting
is this case
where i have uh let's see maybe i'll use
orange
i have some bad points inside of here
some uh you know bad
points inside of here some singularities
okay so
these are singular points these are uh
yeah singular points so there could be
some really bad stuff here cliffs and
cusps and you know one over z's maybe
i'm integrating log of z
uh you know and i'm integrating it
around um
the origin where we know that it's not
analytics so these are points that are
not analytic um
let's just say you know
bad stuff can happen here there'll be
dragons
but let's say that i have a cli i have a
contour
c1
and another contour
c2
and let's say that the function is
analytic
everywhere outside of this region so
let's say that the function away from
these bad singularities it is analytic
everywhere so it's analytic where c1 is
it's analytic where c2 is
i claim
that this is still true the integral
around c1
of f of z dz
is equal to the integral of c2 of f of z
dz
even though now they are not necessarily
equal to zero because if i if i
integrate around singularities again
this is some of the next lectures i'm
going to show you we're going to compute
how to integrate around weird
singularities like integrate the log
function around its origin
which will be 2 pi i for example you
know not zero these integrals around c1
and around c2 might not be zero like
they were in this case but i can still
continuously deform c1 into c2 as long
as it doesn't pass through any
singularities between them as long as
there's no singularities on c1 or c2 or
between them i can deform c1 into c2 and
the integral doesn't change even if i'm
surrounding singularities and i get a
non-zero integral for both of them
and the way we show this is super super
cool
is we basically create a new curve
where we basically take
uh you know the c1 curve
so this is kind of c1
and we take our c2 curve but i'm going
to take minus c2
i hope you see where i'm going with this
this is kind of minus
the minus c2 curve because c2 is going
in the counterclockwise direction so if
i go in the clockwise direction i get
minus c2
and then i kind of have these uh like
this little channel here this like this
little up part and this little down part
of the connector
and if i take the limit as those become
infinitesimally close they equal each
other and they cancel out so this is
super super cool
so what this says
and again now
it's a little hard for me to draw this
but because i have this little gap here
everything in here is analytic
and so this actually satisfies the koshi
gorsa theorem because i have somehow
kind of done some surgery and i've
created this little you know
topologically distinct blue region that
is everything is analytic inside this
blue region that's kind of what i mean
by simple and closed
it's kind of simply connected it's not
two different pieces that are
disconnected it's one connected piece
and it can surround bad singularities
but i have made it so that it is not
closed around those bad singularities
and what we're going to do is take the
limit as this gap goes to zero and those
cancel out
and so what i have is because this does
satisfy koshi gorsa because i have had
this little tiny surgery i've done this
little incision here
what i get
is that the integral
of c1
plus
the integral of minus c2
of minus c2
let's say you know plus this integral
plus this integral but i'm going to take
the limit as they go together so they're
going to cancel so the c1 minus uh you
know plus minus c2
adds up to equals zero because it is
analytic everywhere inside the simply
connected domain
and so what that means is that the
integral of c one of f of z dz
is equal to minus
the integral you know in the
clockwise direction which means it's
equal to plus
the integral in the regular old
counterclockwise c2 direction
that's essentially moving this over to
this side and saying that that minus you
know can mean i can switch the the
direction of c2 back to being
counterclockwise from clockwise
and so this is super super interesting
and again remember these are not
necessarily equal to zero
uh these integrals may vary well
themselves independently c one might not
add up to zero c two might not add up to
zero
but if i go along in c one and then cut
over to minus c2 and then cut back that
total integral equals zero
good
if i was being really really clever or
sorry uh pedantic and uh picky i would
say that i also have a like a you know c
uh you know an integral of c plus and an
integral of c minus you know
the plus direction and the minus
direction but those are going to cancel
out when i take the limit as they get
infinitely close because they're you
know they cancel each other out
so i just need to do this
okay good so this is how we do surgery
in the complex plane super super
important and it allows us to
continuously deform
these contours as long as i'm deforming
them in a region that's analytic if i
don't deform them past a singularity if
there was a singularity between these i
wouldn't be able to do it it would be a
no-go i couldn't do this deformation and
i couldn't use koshy gorsa
so koshi and gorsa are the you know
cracker jack surgeons of the complex
plane and they allow us to do really
really fancy
uh kind of manipulations that are going
to come in handy uh later okay good
one last thing i want to show you
this is actually the easiest thing i've
shown you this is all kind of a little
bit you know takes a takes it stretches
your mind a little bit the next thing
i'm going to show you is actually uh
kind of the easiest integral formula in
the complex plane called the ml bound
i'm going to erase this really really
quickly and write that up and then we'll
be done with this lecture
okay last thing i want to show you is
the easiest kind of integral property in
the complex plane
and it's often called the m
l
bound
and it's super intuitive it's almost so
obvious you would think why did i even
write this down but it's going to be
really useful later when we take
integrals and we take the limit of those
integrals as their radius becomes
infinite and sometimes we can kill
integrals
uh by kind of continuously deforming
them in an analytic regime
domain until the radius is zero
is infinity and we're going to make this
integral uh zero
so if
my function f
has a norm like you know u squared plus
v squared
if the norm of f is bounded is less than
or equal to some number m if it's
bounded it's not infinite it's less than
or equal to m
uh on you know whatever um
this path c and it doesn't have to be a
closed orbit it could be a path from z
naught to z one it could be a closed
orbit it doesn't matter it can it can
contain some singularities or not
doesn't matter
pretty much any function f
as long as it's bounded on this curve
by m
uh and the length of that curve the
length of that curve you know taking the
let's say i have a curve and it's going
from here to here this is curve
and i take you know kind of the integral
of d s the kind of little infinitesimal
length of this
equals l so the length of my curve is l
then
the integral
of that curve over that curve of f of z
dz
the norm of that integral the total
magnitude of that integral if i take
that integral and i take its real part
squared plus it's an imaginary part
squared square root
this has to be less than m
times l
okay that's pretty easy it makes a lot
of sense that if if uh if the length of
this curve is l
and the magnitude of f is never you know
bigger than m
then the total integral over that length
of f can never be bigger than m times l
that's kind of super intuitive and
obvious this is called the ml bound but
one of the things we're going to be able
to do is if we are computing you know
some
super hairy integral you know
over c and i've got singularities inside
and it's a mess and i don't know what to
do what i might do but it's analytic
everywhere out here
i might take the limit of that curve
that contour
out to infinity i might take the radius
out to infinity
and hope that i can show
that f
falls off like 1 over r squared
and my length would be something like pi
times r and so if i multiply them i
would show that this equals zero because
it has to be less than or equal to
something that as i take the limit as r
goes to infinity is r over r squared
uh which would be you know zero so we'll
use the ml bound for things like that uh
later on but it's just kind of a very
intuitive and simple property
okay lots of good good stuff in this
lecture we're talking about how to do
integrals in the complex plane of course
you can use this to impress your friends
at parties
um the koshi gorsa integral theorem uses
the analyticity that's a word of our
function f inside a closed
curve c to show that that integral
equals zero and you can do all kinds of
interesting things like show that
integrals are path independent in
analytic domains you can do surgery to
show that one curve can be continuously
deformed to the other
and so on and so forth so we're going to
use this all coming up soon thank you